Hello, Chae Mi-seon.  We will begin Part 1 of
Chesley Morning, sharing happy investment plans, on Tuesday,
June 23
.
Uh, yesterday's Chinese market.  Yesterday, the Korean market was a
good day, with a very concentrated mix of stocks centered on semiconductors.   Let me hear what
China was like.   yes
.  These days, due to the expiration date of index futures and options, it is
coming up within the upper limit of the index plus 1.8%.  The Black Seon-tae index
fell by 1.2% and 2%, while the regular mega-investment rate
rose again to 3-8 trillion won.   If you look at
the history, 8 trillion yuan in the third case amounts to roughly
800 trillion or 900 trillion.  It practically came up with the
best light recently.
Looking at the sectors, yesterday the finance and industrial
sectors were strong, while the consumer
discretionary and leisure sectors were
weak.  However, all the Jeonse lots have
gone up.  Materials-related stocks surged due to the easing of risk
.  Standard
copper went up 3%, Celadon lithium
4.5%, and Chinese aluminum 5%
.  Stocks
related to the second suspension also
rebounded due to expectations of Ippeuni's performance.  C-tier
went up 5% at midnight and went up 6%, stealing 5% of the energy
.  Yesterday, semiconductor stocks such as Chung-gu,
established semiconductor companies, and Glubal,
led to a very strong performance.  SMS is going up 3%
.  Bupyeong Hwacheon recorded a 3.3% increase,
Joytag Gujun 7%, Maintenance Construction
3.5% and 5%, and Eojeon Tech about 10%,
hitting the upper limit.  And regarding the
construction of the Buhwan Jongri facility, which we know well, all the historical records have been reported.
Oh, regarding the expectations for pretty performance and the
upward correction due to the Gwangtransistor launch, I
also discussed Gwangdongshin-related stocks yesterday.  Jongjae
Ucha reported a historical figure of 1.1%, and
Jongbi Gwang was Gwangseongmi Company.  Yesterday,
A-shares hit the upper limit by about 10%, but
Hong Kong also saw simultaneous listing companies
surge.  Oh, and Jeongtech went up
5%.
Financial stocks also surged due to rising stock market trading volume and an influx of funds for bargain buying.
Whole Life Securities rose 8%, Dongfang Arrest 13%, and
China Acquisition Including
5%.  In particular, Shinhwa is expected to hit the
upper limit by about 10%.  With expectations of
further price increases due to the supply shortage of cooking line art,
the total line is recording 5.9% again,
almost reaching the commercial level.  Arbitration Tech
rose 5%.  Aside from that, stocks related to global equipment
also showed strength.  Employee Tech went up
8%, Yoshi's colleague 4%, and Gilsu
5%.  On the other hand, I learned that the energy-
powered look is relatively pretty
.  Yesterday, I said to set the faith-based salvation interest rate at
1bp.  The tax,
salt, mercy, and foreign currency donation were
well processed, with even 2% inflammation in the parcel.
thank you  Regarding the text you wrote, on the
sixth line, the "
Equipment Ore Island + 10%" and the "Hong Kong Plus +
30" in parentheses refer to when Hong Kong and the mainland are listed together
. It is a public listing. Hmm.  So, it
went up 30% in Hong Kong, but since the upper limit on the mainland is
10%, if it only goes up 10%, it will probably
go up again today.   yes
.  Due to supply and demand, the central zombie
warrior
starts immediately even at 20% or 10% unless there are vehicle issues.   hmm.
[Clears throat]
Looking at it, the Shanghai Index, the Shenzhen Index,
and the CSI 300 have all
risen by more than 1 or 2 percent—I don't think I've
seen that happen easily before.  Uh, if
yesterday was just a
short-term event related to index futures, is it
reversing today?   that's
right.  So, we need to keep a close eye on the market today
.  If the market falls today, the reason it was
called up yesterday is actually
because of futures and options.  However, if it
goes up further today,
there is a possibility that it could be released on March 20.
Because the transaction value has risen to almost 3.8 trillion
.  It is not easy to secure funds for a transaction like this
.  look.  hmm.
All right.
yes.  The index rose quite significantly for the first time in a while
.  Then, let's move on to the trending stocks
.  This is Jangjeon Tech.  I
think this is the stock you introduced us to.
Oh, no.  This is my first time.  [Laughs] Since it's
somewhat similar, I can handle it
.
Uh, Jeonjeon Tech is about 37 trillion at the beginning of this hour
.  Ford Pia is trading at
around 63-fold and hit the 10% upper limit yesterday
. This company is a representative
semiconductor packaging and testing
firm.  This isn't Jeonbiju.   The
company to be announced earlier is currently undergoing maintenance.
This is just pure Hogong, and within the military, the dialogue
company is just one company, Michael Vita
.
Hey, this company maintains a 2% share of MS, which is almost 12%, and ranks about
3rd globally
.  Jung-gu Sijeon
is second place.  The number one global company is
ASE Technology Holdings, and it is a
Taiwanese company.  MS accounts
for 22.5%, and for
Jeontech, overseas sales currently account for
about 78%, and sales to the Chinese military account for about 20%
.  In the first quarter, sales
decreased by 1.8%, but earnings
increased by 42.7% year-on-year.  The GP
margin came out at 14.55%,
expanding by 1.92% compared to the agreement.  MP
Maju agrees to 3% and charges 0.85% for the
prostitution fee.  If you look at the confidence section here,
GP Margin currently has a
78% overseas buying weighting, but GP Maju only
has 12% overseas.  The Chinese
military is 20%.
Other companies are seeing the opposite phenomenon
.
Therefore, if this company increases its sales
costs, the margin
could likely improve.  The sales proportion of high-margin products,
as well as the internal index,
are improving due to the increase in the process utilization rate.  In terms of marketing,
communication maintenance accounts for 32.4%, actual
products for 24%, production for 20%, and automotive
structures for about 6%.  Annual sales of different types
increased by 42% compared to the previous year, and
automobiles increased by 31%
.  GP presented a buy recommendation based on the related refurbished report released a few days
ago, citing increased
sales, rising process utilization rates, and
rising ASP prices
.
There is a possibility that by 2028, the nutritional value sales ratio of movable asset A will decrease from the current 20% to 40%.   The
GP margin for this group is approximately
28% to 35%.  Uh, it's the
official GP
underwater.  There is also Mars in the optical module deal solution area
.  In May, the company
announced a campaign investment plan worth about 10 billion won.  It
increased by about 25% compared to 2015.
There is long-term depreciation and burden.  So
recently, I received it after adjusting the subject.
However, they mentioned that there is a possibility that
margin improvement could exceed market expectations due to the increased re-entry ratio and the rise in the operating rate of the expansion process
.  Based on the related order volume,
sales for next year and the year after next
have increased by approximately 3%, 8%, and 10% respectively compared to the previous period.  The rankings were
2.2 billion, 3.4 billion, and 4.3 billion respectively,
representing 1%, 7%, and 13% compared to the designation.  Next year, applying a 40x multiplier,
TP was formed above.
Hey, regarding the company, in the second half of 2015, you got
one government-run Diford.  At that time, the
target price
was aimed at a 144% increase.  Because it took a 10%
lead yesterday, it has eliminated 20% compared to the closing price
.  Uh, considering Hyun-gu Inyeon's EPS
CGR of 47%, the current pH
is three times that of the top performer. Hmm hmm.  Uh, I do
n't know this company very well, but I'll just take a look at a few numbers and
move on.  If you
look at the line above where the title for Jangjeon Tech is written, it
says the PR is 63 times.   yes
.
However, if you look at the very bottom, it says
110p proposed by applying a 40x PR in 2027.
Yes.  Uh, the
63 Ford P units on the line above where market capitalization is written...
uh, is this still 26 years'
worth?  This is because it is
right before the actual announcement for the second quarter.
Then, regarding the second quarter, third quarter, fourth quarter, and just the first quarter of next year, it is the Ford P that comes out when you mention that bag, and oh, and this Ford P is the Shijon Consus.  If you look at the one below, it
is an estimate from GP Morgan. Hmm,
hmm. The table below shows the estimate released by JP Morgan, and it is
correct.  As Manager Wang
mentioned earlier, the figure labeled
FI262 is still an estimated forecast. If I scroll down
below the valuation section, I see "
Ust P."
Considering adjustment factors, the
PER multiple is set at 61.1x, and for
next year it is 37.7x.
If we apply around 40x for next year, it is 110.  So, there is about a
20% upside compared to the current price
.   You know, when you
look at something like 50x, 60x, or 90x, a 40x one looks relatively cheap,
right?   hmm.
Since this is a circular reference concept, you should look at this term and
bet on it going up; I
don't think it is absolutely cheap or anything like that
.   yes
.  [Clears throat] I definitely did
n't buy it.  Because right now, the leading stock,
ASE Technology Holdings, is trading at around the high
30s
.  When I do it too, I
look at the PG, and it is about 0.78 to 78 times
.
SE AS SE Technology.  However,
AS Technology is doing what it is already doing well, and
the company is
making appropriate moves.  Why is it that the current
sales fertilizer rate for Yeonsan is not changing by 20%?
Most of it is mine.
It's a BC Handphone.  So, if
you look at the GP margin, the GP margin rate is
14%, while the MP margin rate is only 3%
.  And there is one more thing
. This
company is continuously expanding its investments in CPESS
.  We did about 8 billion last year and
about 10 billion this year.
Then, there is also a possibility that Hyunho might get married next year
.
Additionally, there is a possibility of payment for services.
So, the burden of this depreciation may
continue to grow, and
if the reinforcement price is reduced, there is a possibility that the ranking might not turn out well
.  So, I am
giving this multi-strong. Hmm,
I understand.  Lastly, this might be a bit of a silly
question, but you
wrote down 12.2% for the global market.   I think
if this is
exported to a Chinese company overseas, it would be counted as an export. Is it a
Chinese company?  Or are you really
exporting to countries and companies overseas that are not Chinese nationals?
Ah, you can think of it as a Chinese company
.  Ah, yes, because that
company originally had a lot of acquisitions.  Clearly,
two companies here in the military have
acquired
Korean companies. Yes, yes.  So, this
has things like "Forward Korea" and all that.
Confucius has it all, and the
margin comes out.   hmm.
That's true.  The U.S. is currently struggling to block China's
rise in semiconductors and technology, but they are trying to do so
through the acquisition of overseas companies rather than through market entry or exports
.  It seems that things are gradually expanding little by little like this
.
We need to keep monitoring this so that we might be able to gain some clues on when and how to avoid Korea's current
AI-centered upward cycle if it were to reverse
.  yes.   We will
continue to monitor those aspects and
look into the Chinese market together.   yes
.  Let's leave the Chinese market at that
.  Let's find out how the US market performed yesterday with
our Yuri Pro
.
Uh, I will now report on the US market for Monday, the 22nd
.  First of all,
since the market was closed on Friday, it
seems like I've been watching the stock prices anxiously to see how they would move.  First,
looking at the major indices, the Dow and
Russell 2000 rose slightly by 0.29% and
0.83%, respectively.
However, it is worth noting that the SMP
500 declined.  The Nasdaq
fell by more than 1%.  On the other hand, the
Philadelphia Semiconductor Index alone
showed a notable movement, rising 2.04%.  If I were to
summarize yesterday's market in one sentence, I would say it was a day where the spenders
and the receivers were somewhat divided. The
spenders here would be
companies like SpaceX, Alphabet, Google, Amazon, and Microsoft, which need to continue investing in AI infrastructure
.  Conversely, the recipients of the money are
memory and storage companies like Micron, SanDisk, and Western Digital, as well as
semiconductor equipment, optical network, and power
infrastructure companies.  So, I
think it could be said that it was a day when this dividing line became even more distinct.
Well, the current market sentiment is fundamentally based on the premise that
costs—such as data centers, servers, power, and model training—are bound to continue
rising
.  So
ultimately, the key will be which of the Big Tech companies
can recoup these massive investment costs into actual profits, and on top of that, the
U.S. 10-year Treasury yield
surpassed 4.5% again yesterday.  So, with interest
rates once again
surpassing the Human Index of 4.5%, it
seems that the burden has increased for companies that take time to recoup their earnings.  Now, given the situation, it
seems we have no choice but to mention SpaceX, which was the one that started it all.
SpaceX fell more than 16% yesterday and
dropped for three consecutive trading days,
giving back more than a fraction of its market capitalization since its IPO listing day.  The stock price has
now dropped to its lowest level since the first day of listing
.
Actually, it had been falling since before the market opened on Monday
.  So, if we
break down why that might be, I think there are about three
reasons.
First of all, the core reason for the
sharp drop of over 16% yesterday
seems to have been the burden of financing.  It has been reported that
SpaceX is pursuing the issuance of investment-grade corporate bonds worth at least 20 billion dollars, but
in fact, information regarding the bond issuance rights had already been circulating
since last week.
However, it appears that this
acted as the biggest burden again when the market opened on Monday
.
But the important point here
seems to be why they issue those bonds. It’s not like they are borrowing money because they don’t have cash
.  Based on that report,
Space currently holds over 100 billion in
cash, but the
reason they are issuing corporate bonds despite this can be
interpreted as meaning they need to spend that much
.  Well,
we analyzed the IPO earlier and the
Vice President has been continuously mentioning it, but
first of all, it is a temporary short-term bridge loan worth 20 billion that arose during the XAI acquisition process
.  I have to do that car to switch to a long-term company
.
So,
rather than leaving the short-term loan as is, converting it into a long-term company
has the advantage of postponing the immediate financial burden, so it appears they will proceed with this
. At the same time, SpaceX also needs to develop Starship.
And we are in a situation where we have to proceed with all computing investments, including satellite networks, AI infrastructure, and
data centers
.
So, in the case of AI infrastructure, a
large amount of cash is required in the initial stages, but as I have repeatedly
mentioned, it takes a very long time to translate into actual revenue
. Therefore, even if the market currently has over 100 billion in cash, it is really sufficient.  It seems people have started paying more attention to SpaceX and, if so, when this investment can actually
turn into cash
.   hmm.   I did
n't scroll down.  yes.  [Laughs]
Yes.  So, as I keep saying, has the
demand for AI
dropped again?  Rather than that, it now appears that SpaceX is in a situation where the fuel has been added to the fire, given that
doing AI requires spending too much money upfront
.  This
[clears throat] financing burden is
actually not a problem unique to SpaceX
.  Companies like Alphabet, Amazon, and Oracle need to
continuously use large amounts of cash flow to invest in AI and cloud infrastructure, so if
you look at the Big Tech sector, the outlook is all
green.   It
appears that Big Doi has continuously conveyed an atmosphere of some pressure regarding cash procurement.   It
can also actually affect corporate bond issuance and interest rates.  When a large-scale
corporate entity emerges, investors might
sell their existing government bonds
or other bonds to buy that entity outright
.  Therefore, during the
process of issuing this, there is also demand to cancel the interest rate
.  So, if we consider
why the New Year's yield surpassed 4.5% and then crossed back over 5% yesterday, while we
cannot definitively conclude that the entire index decline was solely due to SpaceX, it seems reasonable to assume that
large-scale corporate issuances by AI-related companies
increased the supply and demand burden on the bond market. This
burden, in turn, may have contributed
to a structure where it suppresses growth valuations
.  Lastly, we
can also point out the low volume of distribution, but
first and foremost, the most
critical factor seems to have been the
significant burden of investing in AI infrastructure
.  Now, if you look in the opposite direction and
move to the side receiving the counter-point zone, it
is the semiconductor sector.
This sector was indeed quite strong. This trend is being
confirmed in the ETF sector.
I was thinking about this while reading a Bloomberg report, and what I have been
continuously mentioning domestically is the
Round-1 Memory DRAM ETF. This
Diremite ETF rose nearly 5% early on Monday, and
it was launched in April
.  But after that, it rose by 190%
.  Therefore, while previously one might have used
semiconductor-focused ETFs like SOX or SMH to take a broad approach to AI investment, it
appears that the market is now clearly viewing memory as the next segment of AI infrastructure, leading to a trend of seeking more concentrated products like DRAM ETFs.
There are also continuing to emerge factors that have reignited the fire, and there
are micro-performance results coming up again this week.  The
market will likely seek to verify HBM demand, memory prices,
and guidance on AI server volume.
Additionally, the possibility of SK Hynix
listing in the U.S. is continuing to be pursued. If
this materializes, it will
contribute to creating a channel for U.S. investors to directly invest in AI without relying on core suppliers
.  There have now been
some positive reports regarding the memory industry itself
.  Frith
made an announcement during his visit to China on Monday, and it was a somewhat
unconventional report for the third quarter.  It was predicted that
memory prices could rise by 40 to 50% in the third quarter compared to the previous quarter, and by an
additional 30 to 40% in the fourth quarter.
In particular, as
cloud service providers are
signing long-term supply contracts with a 40% upfront payment condition, memory supply is
being allocated to servers and AI.
So, a
favorable situation continues to unfold between Micron and Hynix,
and additionally, yesterday
Micron
announced a strategic contractual partnership with Entropic.   They
announced that they will supply key memory and storage for the expansion of the Entropy Claude LLM model and will work together to optimize and align with the AI ​​infrastructure from the design stage.
So, Micron
rose about 7% yesterday, which looks pretty cute
.  And
semiconductor equipment stocks, which have been continuing their upward trend since last week, also kept
hitting new highs.
Equipment stocks such as Applied Materials and Lam Research KL were strong,
and
related sectors that had been falling last week also
rose together, as you can see at the bottom, including Lumenton, Coilant, and Sienna
.  Lastly, one
point I would like to highlight is that
I mentioned in my final text that there are now expectations for analog semiconductors. For instance,
Texas Instruments, which can be considered a traditional semiconductor company, has
risen by about 3%.  Uh, however, it would be
difficult to pinpoint this as a single reason, such as it being an AI issue or an extreme one, but
nevertheless, the semiconductor industry is also passing through the seas, trying not to rely on AI data center
power management signal processing, but also on a
wide range of applications like industrial use and automobiles
.   It
seems that the energy is now spreading to them as well.   uh
.  yes.  So, to wrap up yesterday once again, while
the fact that AI investment will continue is important, the
key will likely be who benefits from that investment and who generates revenue
.  Platform companies continue to face the
burden of capital investment and financing costs associated with corporate issuance at interest rates around 4.5%.
I did briefly mention this before, but the
key reason Google dropped 5% was the
risk of C-level executives exiting
.  So,
looking at this, there is no choice but to continuously verify whether those CAPEXs are
recoverable relative to the investment
.
Conversely, for
infrastructure vendors such as memory and storage equipment companies, the key will likely be whether they can secure actual orders
and maintain their pricing power
.  So,
especially since Micron's earnings announcement is coming up this week, it
appears that it will determine whether the memory rally continues. Therefore, the key will likely be not whether
there is demand for AI, but rather
who burns cash within this cycle and
who holds onto that amount
.   That's
all.
thank you  Since the beginning of the year, the US SP
500 and Nasdaq indices
have been rising by around 10%. If you look below, among the M7
or Big Tech
companies—about ten in number—while
there are some that have risen by about 10%, such as Google, Apple, Nvidia, and Broadcom, there are also
many stocks that have fallen by more than double digits. Because of this, it seems that
just a few months ago,
we were frequently encountering the term "market broadening."  As
top-performing stocks by market capitalization have been stagnating and interest has
expanded to mid-cap and small-cap stocks, some
stocks have started to surge, so I do
n't think the term "market framing" can be used anymore.  Right?  Since only a very small number of
stocks are rising—just like the
Korean market yesterday—and as Yuripro mentioned, the US
market is also seeing only those
stocks
receiving immediate cash gains rise, so it
seems true that the overall market sentiment is not good.  Anyway,
President Choi Bu also mentioned that the Greedy & Peer
Index has a peer zone. We
need a market where everything rises together, with the leading stocks rising even more; otherwise, wouldn't the
end be a bit
worse?
yes.  So, while feeling a bit worried, I listened to what
Uripro had to say about the US market
.
yes.  We should move on to the next virtual asset
.  It looks like the materials you prepared today are for IPOs instead of virtual assets
.   yes
.  A domestic company called MadUp is
scheduled to go public on July 1st, and individual investors can
start their subscriptions today.  First of all, let me
give you a brief comment regarding virtual assets. Virtual assets were challenging the
$66,000 level again, but
after blocking resistance, they are now
facing resistance once more around $63,000 and
are currently holding steady.  The biggest reason is that
the risk in the No. 3 market is starting to
decrease again.  I think you can think of it this way
.  There was news about Apollo yesterday, and
requests to redeem shares in the private market
came out at around 17%.  However,
since the cases where redemption requests are accepted are mostly limited to about 5%, we were asked to meet that 5% limit, but
requests came in from around 17%.
Because of this news, yesterday IGB also showed a slight
decline—that is, the software
ETF also plummeted—
and Bitcoin, which tends to move together with that sector, is
also
falling.  You can view it this way
.  [Snorting] Go back to Mad Up
.  Uh, you can think of MadUp as a company that provides AI-based
advertising response and digital marketing
solutions
.  Uh, you can look at the business development side
first.  Uh, based on 25 years, the
marketing business segment accounts for
about 76% of the top portion, so the
marketing business segment is practically the core of the
company.  You can view it this way. I will
focus on the solution business section below later.
As the revenue share of this area increases, MadUp possesses a powerful engine that inevitably leads to improvements in its revenue
structure, revenue mix, and other
aspects
.  I think you
should pay attention to those parts
.  If you scroll down and look, I’ve
simplified the breakdown a bit
.  Initially, the marketing business is about
106%.  We are
responding to traditional digital advertising.
So, this company has
an engine called Lever Expert, and you can
think of it as them utilizing this to advertise more efficiently by taking on large advertising agency work. They
take about 11% to 15% of the advertising costs and
receive additional incentives; it is a
business structure that is simply what I am familiar with
.  And you can
interpret it as almost all of the cache coming out from here.  Uh, since it is said that we have
Samsung Financial affiliates, Olive,
Musinsa, Medi, etc. as clients,
and large advertising
agencies, large consumer companies, and companies like these as
clients, you can think of it that we have these kinds of companies as clients
.
Uh, I’ve highlighted the second solution service
.  It is said that the in-house
developed Level X products are sold directly to external
customers—whether through in-house marketing, third-party companies,
or in the
form of SAS
.  I was most impressed by this sentence: it is a
company that provides solutions to the in-house marketing teams of other companies.  So, you can think of it as a company that provides an engine enabling marketing firms to offer
another marketing solution
.
Depending on the scale of the linked advertising fee, fees are collected in tiers
ranging from 590,000 won to 380,000 won, up to 3,890,000 won
.
When combining with Medium, you will receive an additional
incentive of 1% to 5% of the advertising costs from the media company
.  Uh, it is a
high-margin structure that allows for sales expansion while minimizing manpower input.
Since this involves simply providing the engine, you can view it as an important business unit that
can repeatedly protect against SAS costs and
act as operating leverage
.  So, you can consider that as
the proportion of the marketing business unit gradually decreases and the
proportion of the solution business unit increases,
A Cash will increasingly and repeatedly experience a
greater leverage effect
.
There is also a part called Brand Build-up.  It is a brand that directly incubates brands that are
unable to demonstrate the three key factors of brand value growth
.  So, rather than continuous revenue, I interpreted this as a brand that grows gradually with each project, so I viewed it as a business that falls short of that.  You can
think of A Lever Expert as an
AI engine that performs the tasks of digital marketers on behalf of humans
.  So, it is not just a
B-tool that simply shows you a 15-board—that is, a
business intelligence tool—but rather it
automates the entire process of a marketer's work, from data collection and analysis to creatives, production, media operations, and budget optimization
.  Since the cost structure of digital response consists of
labor costs plus labor-related expenses accounting for
about 80%, it is
said that these repetitive and manual tasks are made efficient through AI.  Uh, since its technological capabilities have been proven through academic papers and
there are analysis results showing that it demonstrated superior efficiency compared to actual human marketers, I think you can
consider it to be quite a well-proven aspect
.  It is said that external integrated analysis is difficult because various ad exposure
media are processed via the Claude API
.  So, regarding this sentence, the
labor costs plus
personnel-related expenses that I highlighted above account for 80%.
This is actually a sentence that shares the same meaning
.  For example, you
can advertise on Google, Meta,
Snap, and various
other social media platforms, but I hear that the
marketing forms or ad impression
forms required by each platform differ.  So, because
all of these things have to be adjusted individually,
labor costs and labor-related expenses
accounted for a
very large proportion of the digital advertising sector. You can view this person as a Level Expert at MadUp who can help make that
cost structure more efficient
.  RedUp reportedly established a pipeline to apply pre-processing, combined post-processing, and internal pre-processing
to further develop this level of export, while maintaining R&D
costs at 10% to 15%
.  So, in the
process of continuously developing Irever X, it is a
company that is ultimately responding to digital advertising.  So, you can view it as us continuously introducing the digital
advertising Noahwood
into Level Ex, and as for the
engine, you can see that it has evolved to this point by continuously redefining the parts that can be
made more efficient as leverage
.  The
company was founded in 2015, and since we have been
continuously discussing Level X-related matters since 2018, you could
say that we have poured a lot of effort into Level Expert for almost 8 or 9 years.
We introduced Level Expert in 2024, and turned a profit starting in 2025
.  So, this is the section where I am
progressing while acknowledging to some extent that Level Expert is effective
.  You can view it this way
.  So, regarding M-Lovin, it
seems we can view M-Lovin as the leading stock in the advertising edtech sector.
M-Lovin's engine, Exun,
has been driving M-Lovin's stock price up until now.  You can think of M.Lovin's X as actually being an
engine sandwiched in between those auctions.
So, if we consider Mroben’s X as the company that acted as a go-between for those who need advertising and those who need to advertise,
facilitating a more efficient auction process, then
a weekly assessment that MadUp’s Level Expert is closer to an AI marketing operation engine that integrates and manages external advertising platforms seems to fit it better
.  So, I
think the most appropriate way to view Level Expert is as a leg engine that simply operates the advertisements themselves, rather than connecting people who need them with ads.  Oh, if you come
down and look, the one at the bottom
was that paper.  If you scroll down and
look, you can start by checking the distribution volume
.  The distribution volume is
good.  You could say it is in good condition, but the
most regrettable thing is that the
volume held by existing shareholders is very large.
You can look at the circulating volume below that. Although the
combined volume of existing shareholders in this public offering is only about 10%, the
volume held by existing shareholders ends up being close to 20%
.  So, you can consider the
total tradable volume to be about 30%, and
30% of the tradable volume is just average.  You can consider it a figure that is
neither too good nor too bad, but
here is a hint and a trick
.  If you look at the very top,
there is also about 13% of the volume subject to the one-month mandatory distribution limit.  So, after about a month,
the locked-up volume will be released, and the
structure is such that it could face significant pressure in terms of supply and demand.  You can
think of it as that kind of company.   If you take a look, the
plan for the use of funds has been
posted to the business.  They mentioned that they would invest about 2.1 billion won in AI investment,
including AI facility investment and operating costs, and if
you look at the very bottom,
there are costs for capital contribution and operation of the local U.S. subsidiary.  So, what the sales business intends to do now is
expand into the US or other larger advertising markets, rather than the domestic one, and directly enter those markets
.  So, they are
now stating that they will continue to provide advertising services by capturing those long-tail companies, and you can confirm the part where they mentioned that they will invest the most in 2026 and
progressively invest in labor costs and operating expenses in 2027 and 2028
.  I brought the performance
table because there is material from the Eugene Investment administration
.  Ultimately, you will be
able to confirm that operating profit has turned positive starting from 2025, and the
company and related parties are continuously emphasizing that this can continue to act as operating leverage for AdUp
.
Since most public offering stocks consist of companies with established earnings, there are very many cases where they
review earnings based on a 2025 full-year period or use a
2025-year valuation standard—
that is, rather than future projections—and
apply a valuation to current earnings to apply a slight discount
before launching the public offering
.  In the case of Mather, we currently conduct the valuation by discounting the
earnings I just mentioned—specifically, how much was earned this
year based on last year's
figures—and by slightly discounting the 2025
valuation to get the 2026 valuation.
However, AdUp has now
turned a profit and is demonstrating that it can
continue to operate at a profit through 2026 and 2027
.  So,
according to the performance table of the Eugene Investment administration, they are continuously mentioning that operating profit is jumping up
from around 8.5 billion to 12 billion, 23 billion,
22 billion, and even 20 billion
.  If you
look at the valuations of the advertising tech (EdTech) sector right now, most of them are
set between 20x and the high teens.
So, if you multiply the ranking profit, I
personally think it might receive a value of around 200 million to 250 billion won.  Of course, that is the case if it is
released as is, but since the
solution business unit generating the most revenue is ultimately the most
important factor, I think it would be good to
carefully monitor whether that part is actually achieved
.  If you scroll down and look,
there was data showing the valuation from the same report by Eugene Investment.
So, you mentioned that the average PER for
edtech companies and ad-related advertising
firms is currently around
24 times, but by
discounting that by about 30%, the
stock price has formed at around 8,000 won at about 11 times
.  The estimated market capitalization was
confirmed at 150 billion won as the valuation was finalized yesterday.   As
I mentioned earlier, the net
profit for the year is about 12 billion. So, if
we
simply assume a loss of about 20 times that amount, the
estimated market capitalization
could reach around 250 billion or 240 billion. If that
happens, there is still about 60%
upside remaining.
So, considering that the public service price is
at the upper end of the range, and when the agency
forecasted demand, the competition
rate was about 1,400 to 1
.  So, personally, I think that when those aspects are taken
into account, it could become a very
successful IPO
.   I
think we need to examine various investment points to see if that is the case.  The first is operating
leverage.  As I mentioned earlier, we have been
continuing to operate our business through this lever and that lever expert, and
since its full-scale introduction in 2024, we have turned a profit and the
operating profit margin has been improving, a
point that both the company and I have been continuously
mentioning.  As I
mentioned earlier, the company is expanding into overseas markets
.  Since the U.S. market is
overwhelmingly larger, we are trying to continue doing business by targeting
local advertisers in the U.S. If
this continues, we believe that
eventually, as the proportion of exports
increases, we might be able to see a picture where the company's product mix
improves and the operating profit margin rises; however, it does
not seem like a picture that we can see in the short term
.  So, it's been about 27 or 28 years
.  As for number 2,
since they have just established the corporation and are proceeding with operations, we need to wait and see how things turn out later. You can
consider it to have a somewhat weak investment appeal
.  The third is a growing
treatment.  This
is an ongoing investment point.  The healing rate is
rising significantly.  The CAGR is
coming out at around 50% based on the handling standard, but you
should not view this handling as revenue. You
should consider it as the size of the advertisement itself. From there, as I
mentioned earlier, if you consider it an ad
response business, you can view it as a picture where you can capture about 15%
.  So, the fact that Twico itself, where the
MadUp advertisement currently has exposure, is
growing in size is
very encouraging, and it accounts for
about 3.6% of the market.  In terms of CAGR, that part has
been showing over 33% since 2018, so it is a
company that is steadily expanding its market.
I think we can summarize the three investment points like this.  So, I
think I can just state the conclusion.
MadUp is an AI marketing company that goes
beyond being a traditional advertising agency to automate
performance marketing tasks through its engine and level experts
.  So, it is an AI marketing company that aims to perform the
advertising agency business, which typically requires a lot of human intervention, with
greater efficiency
.  Currently, the growing
marketing response business is leading the way, but I would
say that future valuations will be determined by the solution business and the AI ​​Manager service
.  The fact that it demonstrated accelerated operating leverage by utilizing its own engine Level X.
So, regarding the 300 figure for
2025, sales were 35 billion won, and the
operating
profit was -400 million won in 2024. However, when it
came to 2025, sales jumped to 50.2 billion won, and
operating profit rose to 8.5 billion won. As a result, it
seems they have turned a profit and have
entered the process of going public. You can view it that way
.  The actual launch of Level
Expert was in July 2024, but it
turned profitable in 2025. Since the Solution Business
Unit, which sells Level Expert as I mentioned earlier,
showed a 121% YI in the first quarter, I think it is true that expectations for future performance
continue to exist
.  While it is encouraging that the
liquidity is in the low 30% range, the
fact that the 14% lock-up is released immediately after one month suggests that while the short-term trend is
favorable, time must be taken to reduce the volume while continuously proving performance in the mid-to-long term.
Finally, regarding risks, the
portfolio and advertising channels focused on domestic companies
could act as a double-edged sword.
Therefore, since there is currently no overseas revenue at all,
in order to eliminate concerns regarding the valuation, it is
necessary to increase the number of customers and related revenue from overseas subsidiaries
.  I think I can provide guidance like this. In
the short term, as I mentioned earlier, after the
listing,
demand from institutional investors is very good, and they also
want to participate in the public offering of MadUp with our commitment.  They say that about 27%
responded that way
.  So, in the short term, it is very
encouraging that the public offering is at the upper end, that institutional investors are very interested,
and that the circulating volume
remains at around 30%, which is very
positive. However, we can conclude that this is an IPO that
may only see a short-term surge
.   That's
all.
thank you  In the past, the advertising market relied on
traditional media such as TV, radio, and newspapers. These traditional
advertising channels remained firmly established for decades, perhaps even
over a century, with
global corporations and
two or three companies in Korea
growing into overwhelmingly large enterprises.
However, with the advent of the Internet and online
marketing, companies
utilizing software for online
and targeted marketing emerged. These were
relatively small-to-medium-sized
enterprises that continued to capture market share and secure profits. After
listening to the explanation of MadUp provided by Chief Junyeok today, it seems that the marketing sector—which
utilizes digital marketing software and even
AI engines—is
currently in a highly competitive, "
Warring States" era.  There are
quite a lot of competitors, so certain companies are bound to pop up in the
future. While
MediUp is likely one of those candidates, it is too
early to say that it is the overwhelming leader right now. So, from that
perspective, if you
approach it from a short-term investment standpoint and
observe whether a market leader emerges, you will
likely be able to select a company that records very good returns over the long term.   yes
.   Just by
looking at the number of companies continuously advertising using AI engines, I strongly felt that the overall business conditions for advertising agencies would likely
deteriorate significantly
.  So, I
didn't realize the labor costs were this high, but
using the AI ​​engine, the
time saved was almost tenfold or
more.  So,
looking at those aspects, I
think it would be good to conclude by thinking that digital marketing firms that relied on human intervention would face significant difficulties and could be easily replaced.   I
agree.  yes.   yes
.  Some parts of today were a bit long.
Uh, today, ah, I will
conclude Part 1 of the analysis report on the Korean MadUp IPO scheduled to be listed on July 1st
.
Thank you to everyone at Jamitan for joining us for Part 1.  We will
see you in Part 2 shortly.
thank you
Hello.  Join us for a happy investment journey
with the Chesley Investment Exhibition. We will begin today's Chesley Morning
Brief, June 23rd, in the order of Pi
.   Well
, since it covered everything from IPOs to some parts, it was
very good.
Originally, when you start by analyzing public offerings, you study
companies by
looking not only at asset and earnings values ​​but also at relative values, comparing them with the valuations of listed peer groups.
Since you need to look beyond just IPO companies to include established ones,
analyzing IPOs is a very beneficial aspect during your junior years. I
think it would be good for you to take an interest in this when analyzing IPOs.
Okay, so the US market
ended mixed.  Uh, the Philippine rose by 2%,
but looking at the Nasdaq, which fell by 1.3%,
everything is dropping except for Tesla and the big tech stocks below
.
yes.  And Space dropped 16%,
you know.
yes.  yes.  Actually, looking at it, it is
not yet included in the NASDAQ Backswing, but since it was listed on NASDAQ, it is
included in the NASDAQ index.
But that... ah, it's
not the Nasdaq 100, but it will be
included in the Nasdaq index.   Because it
includes several thousand Nasdaq indices
.
But as much as
3% of that is included.
The proportion is as much as 3%.
yes.  Since it dropped 16%, if we consider the 3, it means
one
stock has shifted gears by almost 50bp.
So, I think the Nasdaq index will be quite volatile because of SpaceX, and it is being added to the Nasdaq 100 in early July.  Then, even
within that, the weight itself probably wo
n't be small, but it
seems it will affect the overall index.
In the future outlook, Space Sex had a slightly negative impact on
overall sentiment toward tech stocks yesterday
.  And if you look, the international
10-year bond
yield rose to 4.55%, while oil prices
fell by 2.2%.  But what
I see here is that yesterday,
shortly after listing, SpaceSex
disclosed that it would be raising funds again through bonds.
yes.  At the same time, I thought that as the demand for
funds itself
increases across the money market—especially among hyperscalers and Big Tech companies—it might have become a factor that leads to a
slight increase in interest rates, whether in the government bond market or the corporate bond market
.  So, it was
observed that companies currently conducting CAPEX or those likely to do so in the future were all declining.   People are saying that
software companies, in particular, have fallen significantly.
Palantia also
dropped about 7% yesterday, and
is down 32% year-to-date.  And Mnevin... well,
companies like Oracle and Robinode
declined, and the only thing that was right was the
semiconductor industry, which is benefiting from KEPFIX
.
So, first of all, if you look at the
corporate disclosure regarding the bond issuance by Spex and the
news from Gullberg, they stated that the
purpose of the bond issuance is to
repay capital gains and general business operations, but
the market estimates that they will raise at least 21 dollars
.  However, the
cash and cash equivalents disclosed by the company on June 19th amount to
about 100 billion.   However,
among this, 75 billion would likely be
funds raised through IP. If we
look at why they raised funds despite holding massive cash reserves, it is possible to estimate that while the
borrowing rates for existing arbitrage loans were somewhat high, issuing it now would allow them to
raise funds at a more favorable level
.
And then, when considering why they would go out of their way to issue another
100 billion when they already have that amount to
repay existing profits, it
is judged that it is highly likely that the funds for this
100 billion have already been allocated for purposes such as AI CAPEX. In fact, regarding the purpose of fund utilization announced by the company after the IPO, they stated that they would use 75 million
dollars for AI computing, infrastructure expansion, and the like
.   If
you look below,
oh, if you look later, regarding Bloom, since
SpaceX hasn't been listed for long,
about one or two people have already
made estimates.  Although the estimates made by about two people are
somewhat unreliable, if we take a look, the total
scale of Space's CAPEX for this year and next year is around
100 billion.
yes.  So, the
existing funds already have a designated use, and I
suspect that for the funds approaching maturity, they might have opted to issue new funds to extend the maturity period. [Clears throat]
Yesterday, it fell by about 16%, and
there is an ETF called 2Q that tracks the Nasdaq index.
Through this, we can estimate that it may be included in the Nasdaq index to a certain
extent.
Currently, the market capitalization is around 2.18%, and
SpaceX is
included in a Nasdaq index-tracking ETF that accounts for about 3%.
Since this is an estimate of the Nasdaq index, it is possible to estimate that it has been
incorporated into the Nasdaq index to some extent
.
Because this 3% is a significant weighting, it
had some influence on the Nasdaq index. Since it
fell by about 16% yesterday, multiplying
3 by 16
gives about 0.48, so it is estimated that it
contributed -0.5%, or 5 percentage points, to the Nasdaq index
.  And
since it is scheduled to be included in the NASDAQ 100 early in early July, it is
expected to act as a volatility factor for the NASDAQ 100 index once it is also included. Therefore, I think that
indices such as the NASDAQ, where Big Tech holds a significant weight, and the NASDAQ 100, which will include Space, might be at a
slight disadvantage for the time being
.
Looking at annual performance,
revenue could be divided into various segments, but if we
look at it as a whole, the
reliability of the consensus is already significantly low because there are currently only two analysts making estimates
.  But just to
get a general idea of ​​the trend, if we look at roughly
what kind of picture analysts
estimate will unfold,
Revenue for 2026 is
expected to be around $35.8 billion.
Operating profit is expected to be around 3 to 3.3 billion
dollars.
And going down below that, EPS is
expected to be around -$1.1 to $1
.  Based on EPS, it
is expected that this company will reach its turnaround around 2028.  So, the important thing is that since it has a
large market capitalization and
holds a certain position in the U.S. market, there may be
some who are expecting inclusion in the S&P 500. However,
since the
S&P 500 requires recording a profit for at least four quarters annually, based on EPS, it is expected that there will likely be a possibility of inclusion in the S&P 500 only after 2028
.
Ah, and if you look at the Capital Exchange section below,
uh, this year is about 45 billion
.  Next year will be about 55 billion years, and the year
after next
will be about 664 billion years.  So, based on
free offering flow or
surplus offering flow (operating cash flow minus CAPEX), it is
expected that surplus offering will be recorded only in 2029.
Before that, CAPEX is expected to be between 40 and
60 billion, and after that, between
70 and 90 billion, indicating that
massive investments are
expected to be made in the future.
So,
since this much investment is involved, we should keep in mind that the point at which
free cash flow
turns positive may be somewhat
variable depending on the top line and cash generation ability
.
Ah, so continuing on, regarding the
hyperscalers, I
reported this morning that the CAPEX estimates were revised following Oracle's earnings announcement. While
the estimates continue to be revised upwards, if we look
back and examine the total
cash flow of the five hyperscalers
due to the cash backs, and
see how the market views the current situation, to start with the
conclusion for 2026 and 2027, it is projected that
operating cash flow
will record a negative figure
.  In other words, the situation is that
CAPEX is set a little higher than operating cash flow
.  And it is projected to
turn positive in 2028, though we will have to wait and see. In
any case, the market
expects significant capital expenditures to occur by 2026 or 2027, and
accordingly, aggressive investment is anticipated to continue
even until the foreign currency cash flow turns negative
.
So, coupled with these factors, just as
Yuri Pro mentioned this morning, I think the
differentiation in stock prices and the
divergence in momentum between the beneficiaries of this CAPEX and those executing it will likely continue for the time being
.
With Micron's earnings announcement just around the corner, a
lot of forecasts are continuously being released.   The
content is quite similar, and they continue to
give positive evaluations of Micronet. Yesterday, a
brokerage firm called Jefferies released a report called the Memory Outlook
.
Uniquely,
rather than presenting their own perspective, they
invited a former Samsung China employee named Tan and included the content of their discussion
in the report.  So, regarding those
aspects, some parts of what was discussed are
somewhat general, while
others are a bit aggressive. In particular,
regarding the price outlook that I have been continuously following, a significantly
aggressive forecast was presented.   To begin
with, the conclusion is that price hikes
will defy expectations and China will
not pose a threat until 2027.
Regarding supply, it is stated that global memory
supply will only increase by 7 to 8% in 2026, and that shortages in
DRAM and NAND will
persist even in 2027. At
the core of this is the price outlook; regarding the
price forecast for DRAM and NAND in a report recently published by Citi, they
mention that this
aspect is slightly more conservative than what they view.
Looking at Citi's price forecast,
DRAM is projected to grow by 13% in Q3 and
11% in Q4, while NAND is projected to grow by
17% in Q3 and 6% in Q4. Based on this, Citi
forecasts an overall DRAM YY price growth rate of 200% for the year, or 186%, whereas
here at Jefferies, the
Q3 price forecast is much more aggressive, projecting
40 to 50%.  They released a very aggressive forecast for the 4th quarter, ranging
from 30 to 40 percent
.  I
think that yesterday might have had a slight impact on the market regarding this aspect as well.
Depending on how Micro handles this during their earnings announcement, it seems like there might be some volatility on the day, but in
any case, the outlook
itself seems to have been the most aggressive among the forecasts seen so far
.
The rest is all pretty standard content.
Regarding HBM, it was mentioned that there is a supply shortage, and
considering the capacity expansion in 2026 and 2027, the
price increase for HBM over the next 12 months is
expected to be around 70%
.  So, regarding the overall annual memory price
forecast, in the case of A City, it is
about 200%, but in the
case of Jefferies, since they set a very aggressive overall annual memory
price forecast for the 3rd and 4th quarters, they expect
memory price growth to
reach six times the previous year in 2026,
slow to 40 to 45% in 2027, and
wafer capacity to expand by 15 to 20% in 2028,
and although unlikely, they
anticipate a price decline if AI demand slows down
.  So, the discrepancy between 26 and 27
is quite significant.
And regarding the LTA long-term supply contract, we are currently
signing it only with cloud service providers, with a
40% upfront payment and a
50% share, but they are saying that it can be expanded up to 70%
.  And Samsung is saying that there is a possibility of signing a
3-year LTA contract with a major cloud service provider
.
Suppliers
are taking a cautious stance on expansion, and major memory
manufacturers are saying that they have little motivation to aggressively increase capacity due to bad experiences from past cycles
.  They emphasized that they are taking a very cautious stance on capacity expansion, stating that even if they
receive 40% in donations, they plan to re-evaluate the sustainability of demand every year
.  Ah, regarding the China variable, it is
said that it cannot be a threat in the 2026-2027 upcycle due to the technological gap. Ah, China's capacity expansion only
affects the low-end segment, but it
poses a long-term threat to NAND. It
was also mentioned that CXMT's DRAM technology is 1.5 to 2 generations behind, and DDR6 HBM 3e is impossible without EUV.  And it was mentioned that while HB is expected to
increase in 2027, it will still
lag behind by two generations, and the gap is
expected to widen.
So, what I paid attention to was that the
price outlook seemed quite aggressive
.  I
think the key will be how much Micron Technology confirms this aspect during their earnings announcement.  That's all.
All right.
Uh, the part that was really important and that I was quite concerned about
was the threat from Chinese companies. For now, they wo
n't be threatening until 2027, and that will actually be the case.   I'll probably see
.
And while it comes out as 1, the NAND is a
long-term threat,
and the fact that CXN DRAM technology is
1.5 or 2 generations behind
doesn't mean it will be 1.5 or 2 years.
Ah, it seems you viewed this at the nano level
.  We are currently in the
era of the original C.  10. It was in the
early 10nm range, 10nm, and 11nm. However,
since CXMT is a 16nm generation, it is about 2 generations.  Then, if it goes up to about a generation
and then
to Nano C,
wouldn't that mean EUB won't work?  Ah, it is possible to
do it with DUB, but since it involves double and
triple patterns requiring 2- and
3-layer stacking, if the production cost becomes extremely high,
will Changsin Memory release HBM 3e next year?   We are
currently planning to release HBM 3 by the end of this year
.  Yes, until this year
.  I'm not sure about 3 2 yet.
Ah, the 3 will be released this year.  It's set up like this
.
All right.
And the long-term supply contract plan here is also
written very well in detail.  Looking at it.
yes.   It is
stated that there is a 3-year long-term supply contract, and that too, after receiving the 40th election payment, this is the current situation
.
Now, the
free cache flow of these hypersploits is
negative this year and through next year.
Yes, that is correct.  Right now, uh, according to
Bloomberg's estimates, it is like this, but I
think it could go even further into the negative
.
Yeah, right.
yes.   That is correct.
Due to the rootless rise of the M7 up until last year,
yes,
when the US was exceptional in 2023 and 2024, it was the
M7 that led the market
.  yes.
Why are
n't the profits coming in for those who invested late?
yes.  You are likely doing that, but looking at the
free cash flow—which serves as the financial resource for actual returns—
starting to decrease into negative territory from 2024 into 2025,
recording negative figures in 2026 and 2027, and only
expected to increase significantly again in 2028, I am thinking that looking at this alone, I should
buy some more around the middle or end of next year
.  So, I
think the key to this investment is accurately identifying where the inflection point of the cycle is right now.  In my view, once
this infrastructure cycle ends, a
winner will definitely emerge and
take almost everything. I think that
at that time, it would be meaningful to invest by meaningfully capturing and leading that winner
.
But usually, when the
time for restructuring comes, the winners
don't emerge.  So,
among the hype skills that are currently being thrown around, especially regarding the
AI ​​side—whether it's Open AI, Anthrotic, or
Fun AI—
all three
might coexist, or the third might differ. Since
things are changing so much and so quickly, it
seems difficult to predict.
But whoever it is, there is
really no way to know.  Anyway,
since this is a phase where money is being spent very aggressively, I
think we should focus a little more on the beneficiaries for now.
[Clears throat]
First off, right at the very front, they are
borrowing money just to survive and continuing to
struggle.
Yes.
In President Choi Bu's view, this
free casher might have a deeper negative range
.   Because we have to
spend more, right?   That you're
thinking that way again.  It's just like
that theory called the sin dilemma, you know.   We could just handle it
well in the negotiation, but since we do
n't know how the other side will handle it, let's just
go for it and
think about it later.
I think that kind of pattern is appearing.   I expected that, but so
far it is safer than the offering price
.  The offering price was 130, but it's
154.6, so it's 6. Yes,
but since early inclusion in the NASDAQ is
scheduled, I think there will
be a slight rebound before the NASDAQ backlist inclusion. However,
those who invested based on the event drive for that NASDAQ inclusion
[clears throat] might be a bit flustered
.
yes.
However, even if we add it this time,
if the stock price doesn't go up, I do
think we should slightly reduce our weighting and wait and see, regardless of whether it rises or not.   The
PSR is 100 times right now.
Well, anyway, personally, I
think that even the event participation isn't easy. As I briefly
mentioned last time, if Nalssakbaek is incorporated, it will account for about
1% of the weight.   It went in with a
weight of about 1%, but
that 1% isn't really that big of an impact
.  So, even if you
mechanically buy ETFs that track the Nasdaq, in
my view, considering these
fundamental
factors, they do
n't seem to have much appeal personally.   yes
.
yes.   Since
I am someone who thinks in the mid-to-long term, I am
considering whether the upcoming events will make it easier to plan trading strategies
.
And yesterday, there was
an article related to SpaceX in the Washington Park newspaper,
yes.  yes.  Yes.
There is a book written by an American professor couple, and this was an
introduction to that book.
Yes.
Uh, Elimus talked about
1 million people on Mars in 2050,
1 million people.   I was
thinking, "Could a city with as many as a million people be built on Mars in 2050, or maybe four or four years from now?" But
the professor couple said, "
Yes, the
Earth's environment after it is destroyed by nuclear war will be
better than Mars."  Uh,
conversely, if I were to [sniff],
Mars is a bit, uh, anchored and weak
.  yes.
And if you try animal testing or something like that,
yes.
Our DNA is aligned with the gravity of this Earth, isn't it?
So when you go to space or something, the
gravity changes, and
um.
At that time, they wrote about various things, from whether childbirth would go well or whatever—up to
60 degrees—and
all sorts of other things. In short, looking at the description that the conditions are worse than a post-nuclear war destroyed Earth, just looking at that alone, I thought, "Okay, then [snorting] 1 million people in fossils might be a bit off." I don't know how much technological development will have occurred by then, but it will likely be a bit
.
Okay, that's all for the US. Yes, let's
move on to the domestic market.
Yes, I will report on yesterday's market.   The
KOSPI
closed with gains of about 0.7% to 7%.   The
KOSDAQ closed with a flat gain
.
In terms of supply and demand, there was an inflow of buying pressure in the 2 trillion won range from individual investors
.  On the other hand, foreigners
took significant profits, with
sales of approximately 2.5 trillion won.   On
the other hand, I also received about 300 million won from institutions
.
Looking at investor trading trends, foreign
investors bought LG Innotek,
HD, Hyundai Heavy Industries, Mirae Group, Samsung Electronics, Doosan,
SK Telecom, IPS, and others yesterday
.  For the sell orders, SK Nix, SK
Square, Samsung Electronics, Samsung Electro-Mechanics, Hyundai
Motor, LG Electronics, etc. were sold.
Institutional buying included SKX, Samsung Electro-Mechanics,
SK Square, LG Electronics, and others
.   On
the other hand, on the selling side, Samsung Electronics, Hyundai Motor,
Hyundai Heavy Industries, and Hyundai Mobis
were sold.   A
total of 19 stocks hit 52-week highs, and
on the KOSPI, I bought SK Nix and SK Scare
Holdings.  Other than that, I
bought Samsung Electro-Mechanics preferred shares, etc.   With
PSK, Jeju
Semiconductor, Hana Micron,
Tess, VM, and Gigavis
hitting new highs on the Postdaq, semiconductor materials, parts, and equipment stocks on the KOSDAQ
showed considerable strength.
No, foreigners have just doubled the KODEX SK
Hynix price like this
.   yes
.  139.
And the principal
sold this much,
yes.
Uh,
that's a bit strange.  Right?
Buy both.
Why do you think that, Dr. Wang?   I don't know
.  I cannot distinguish why this leverage is being bought from an
external individual or an
institution.   I know
.   Could it be a
black-haired foreigner?   hmm.
I think so too. There are
15, no, 19 stocks that hit a 52-day high
.  Okay, let's take a look at the
trading activity of the major stocks.   yes
.  Looking at the semiconductor vector first,
Samsung Electronics closed at a weak level, and the
differentiation in stock prices with SK Hynix continues to
appear.  Hynix
rose 5.6%, and it seems to have been maintaining a strong performance on its own for about
two weeks
. The gap continues to
widen, and yesterday, excluding preferred shares,
Hynix caught up with Samsung Electronics' market
capitalization to
become the number one. However, if
preferred shares are included, Samsung Electronics can still be
considered the number one in market capitalization for now.  Materials, parts, and equipment (
Sobujang) stocks were also quite strong; Hanmi Semiconductor rose 2%, and stocks like HPSP, EOTech, One Nigaipass, IS, Simtek, and Doosan Tessa generally increased by as little as 2% and as much as 7-8%. It seems that
previously, signs of warmth spreading within the Sobujang sector were
appearing.  In the IT sector,
Samsung Electric
showed signs of taking a breather.  It fell by 1.8% and 8%
.
LG Electronics' stock price had been falling continuously recently, but it did manage to
rebound somewhat in the market
.  The platform
sector is generally continuing its sluggish trend, and with
Naver's
stock price falling significantly again, the forward P has
dropped to 16 times.  The DK
index closed up about 1.5% to 5%, and the
semiconductor sector performed well as expected.  Tokyo
Electron rose by over 3%.  Murata
4%,
Disco, Advantest, and others generally
showed strength.  So yesterday,
Murata showed strong performance [clearing throat], but
Electric
appeared relatively weak.  It appeared that the
electricity that kept Ibi and Murata strongly maintained also
eventually followed.
So we need to look at the additional trends, and the
automotive sector was bad yesterday.
Hyundai, Kia, Mobis, and AutoEver
all closed lower.  Certainly, as
the probability of an interest rate hike this year
increases and the FOMC takes a somewhat hawkish stance, it
seems that growth stocks linked to robotics, such as the robots on the KOSDAQ and POSCO Pain, are losing momentum.  The consumer goods
sector, well, was generally sluggish, mainly due to large cosmetics brands
.  Pio beauty devices
were somewhat mixed; while
Clena Pharma and AP were weak,
Shuzel and
[Kotbangwi] Wontech ended on an upward trend again
.  The food and beverage sector
closed weak, with Nongshim's stock price showing weakness
.
Oh, the department store chain was good.  The
upward trend at Shinsegae and Hyundai Department Store is coming to an end.
Oh, if you take a look at the shipbuilding, steel, and other sectors,
shipbuilding stocks all fell significantly yesterday without any particular issues
.  I
finished it with one Ocean and one Engine Accessory
.  So, everything has dropped significantly, with Hyundai Heavy Industries
, Hana Ocean, and
Hana Engine trading at less than 20x their previous levels,
and the steel and chemical sectors below also
generally closed lower.   If
you look at defense stocks, Hana and Yeoro are likely to remain flat
.  Rotem was weak during the Nex-era.   I
remember that when the market opened yesterday, the Bangsan stock price was fine, but it closed with a slight decline as sell orders poured in immediately.  I noticed that the
stock price of Rheinmetall in Europe was quite
weak.  The peak was
probably 2,000 euros, but now it has
dropped to about 100 euros.
April
dropped almost to a simple level. Yes, that is
correct.  You could say that the stock price has
fallen quite a bit; it actually
dropped significantly starting from when talks of a global ceasefire began to emerge.
Recently, Rheinmetall has
missed earnings for three consecutive quarters due to individual issues
.  So, the situation is relatively
weak, and domestic defense stocks are also quite
weak
[clears throat],
but anyway, I do feel that times like this have always been
opportunities.
And the bio sector was generally
stable.  Well, the KOSPI and
KOSDAQ biotech sectors
showed weakness, and the financial and
securities stocks below also performed poorly.  In the entertainment sector,
HYBE fell significantly by 4.7% yesterday without any particular issues, and the
others were similar.   I
remember the variable instrument sector doing quite well last Friday, but profit-taking occurred again yesterday
.   yes
.
Now, if you look at our data, the more it
drops, the more it is marked in blue, and the
more it rises
, the more it is marked in red.
Right now, looking at the left side, there is the Semiconductor Materials & Components sector, and at the
top of the IT sector, there is Samsung Electro-Mechanics, Samsung Electronics,
Innotek, and so on.  Next, regarding the
Japanese semiconductor equipment company Tokyo
Electron and
Murata, which is a peer of Samsung Electro-Mechanics, there is
n't much interest.  And if you go straight to the
consumer goods side on the right, you can see
red for Shinsegae Department Store and Hyundai Department Store, and the
automotive sector has been collapsing recently, right
?   yes
.  From shipbuilding and steel to heavy sectors like E-
commerce and
even Ant, the financial sector has also fallen significantly recently.
Kiwoom Securities has dropped 26%, and if you
look at it this way, it
appears the index is rising because our semiconductor weighting exceeds 50%. However, in reality, it
feels like we have entered a bear market, and we have continued to see
downward momentum, right?   yes
.
So, well, it went over 9,000 and was mostly like fruit, but
in fact, the market itself entered the pharmaceutical market
.  But this bear market has
n't shifted into a major downtrend; it's more like the second
half of this year, usually leading up to the midterm elections in
July, August, September, and October. And the term "
bear
market" means that stock prices are currently getting cheaper
.
Because prices are falling, another opportunity is being
created within this bear market
.
Polarization is intensifying significantly right now.   That's right
.   It
seems like this is a common situation in both the U.S. and Korea.
yes.  So, the common, that kind of
market appearance is being revered even more
.
Now, let's take a look at the report you brought
Time for a revaluation of the Korean stock market when income surpasses production.  Uh, one,
Mr. Kim Do-won.
[Clears throat]
Uh, I mentioned that the Black stock market strategy is not to
reduce holdings due to interest rate burdens, but to
buy more of industries where income outpaces production
.  It is said that
in a phase where real GDI has significantly surpassed GDP, a strategy of
focusing on AI bottleneck industries, including memory semiconductors, and
further expanding the weight of export stocks when exchange rates stabilize is
somewhat effective.  Uh, it
is said that financial stocks and high-dividend stocks can be utilized as a complementary axis to rising interest rates, and that they are considered top priority stocks for purchase.  It is said that the essence of the current market trend can be viewed not as an economic
recession, but as a revaluation of Korean companies
.
Well, they say the direction of global monetary policy is
changing, but the government did
freeze the benchmark interest rate.  It is said that price
stability is being prioritized, and the ECB and
BOJ are continuing their normalization stance
.  So, interest
rates, which had been vacant at 22%, were recently raised, and
the Bank of Korea is also raising rates. It is said that there is still some
possibility of a rate hike due to global monetary policy. However,
this current pressure on interest rates can be viewed as being closer to a normalization process
created simultaneously by growth, prices, exchange rates, and income levels, rather than a recession
.  It can be said that Korea’s distinguishing feature
lies in the improvement of income;
while real GDP grew by 3.8% year-on-year in the first quarter, real GDI
increased by 2% to 13.2%, indicating that
income grew much faster than production
.  And this means that the Korean economy has moved
beyond the stage of simply producing more and entered a phase where it can sell at higher prices
.  The key can be seen as the improvement of educational conditions; as
semiconductor prices rise and the
price recovery of HBM memory
occur simultaneously, a
structure is forming that generates high profits from selling the same volume
.  They say the biggest difference is that while past semiconductor
cycles were volume-driven, this
cycle is price-driven
.  It is said that the
phase where GDI outpaces GDP is a
period when income grows faster than production, which can lead to
simultaneous improvements in companies' EPS, cash, and investment capacity
.  So, if
we look at past cases where GDY and GDP reversed, the interpretation might differ slightly between the U.S. and Korea
.   In
the United States, when GDI slows down before GDP, it has served
as a warning signal of a slowdown in corporate profits or wages and credit.
On the other hand, it is said that in Korea, when
export prices
rise faster than revenue prices as a result of changes in educational conditions and purchasing power, GDI
surpasses GDP.  Therefore, it is said that the
current situation in Korea is closer
to a signal of a revaluation of export company profits than a signal of a recession in the U.S., and that
the U.S. is failing to keep up with production of income, with
actual GDP of 1.6% and real
GDI of 0.9% in the first quarter of 2026
.  On the other hand, Korea's actual GDP is
3.8, real.   It is said that it
significantly outpaced income-generating production
.  They said it is the largest discrepancy since 1988
.  GDI went up this
much.   hmm.
[Clears throat]
So, we can interpret number 2 as a result of the rise in semiconductor export unit prices and the
improvement of educational conditions,
and I have
identified about four strategic implications.  First, the
leading stock can still be seen as semiconductors
.  The starting point of this GDI lineup
can be viewed as exports and corporate margins rather than consumption, and HBM
memory equipment, materials, and AI
infrastructure can be seen as key sectors
.  The second point is that the exchange rate limitation can be
viewed as a fire tax on revaluation
.  A weak won is a
factor that increases the profit leverage of export pressure, and once won
volatility stabilizes, the market will
focus on EPS again.  In the past, the
3 trillion won recovery also led to strength
in the Korean stock market as income improvement and the weak won appeared simultaneously
.
Third, it is said that financial stocks and high-dividend stocks
can be used as a security axis
.  If the background for the interest rate hike is nominal
growth and income improvement, an
expansion of the loan-deposit gap may occur, and dividends or
capital measures may come to the forefront.
Fourth, they say that they consider my level to be somewhat lower
.  It was said that since current income growth
manifests first in improvements in corporate profits and investment capacity rather than consumption, it would be
appropriate to approach consumer goods and retail stocks after real wages and consumer sentiment recover. However,
since there are already some stocks in the consumer sector that have surged, it seems this
opinion refers to the consumer sector in general
.  Potential risks
include rising semiconductor prices, rising raw material prices, and excessive interest rate hikes
.  However, the important point is
not the direction of interest rates but the reason for their rise;
in a phase of rising interest rates driven by growth and income improvement, an
approach centered on improvement stocks is more effective.
Furthermore, given that GDI has now surpassed GDP, it can be
assessed that the Korean stock market is currently in a revaluation phase
.
Therefore, since the reasons for the current rise in interest rates
and inflation are
ultimately
based on growth and income improvement, the
increase in interest rates can be
interpreted as a move toward growth rather than a recession.
I think we can summarize the story in that way.
That's an unusual analysis.
So
yes.
When talking about GDP, it is
based on territory, isn't it?   hmm.
[Clears throat] The state
measured the monetary value of the output produced within its territory, whether by domestic or foreign nationals.
However, if we look at the US example, since we are
investing in that company, 40% of US
companies'
SMP is
overseas revenue.  Overseas
sales are not included in GDP, but they
are included in corporate earnings, right?  So,
uh, regarding GDP, I’m not really sure, especially about the domestic side
.
The U.S. tends to view
making board decisions based on GDP as somewhat
inflexible.
And another thing is, yes, they're saying that
real GDI has
significantly surpassed GDP, but I think
everyone has probably felt a bit skeptical about whether our income has actually
increased that much
.  Right?
Sobaek is very
yes.  I did tell Park Lee about it, but it turned out the
income was much higher than I expected
.
More than 15% each with Y and Y.
Uh, regarding the
income here, stock profits are also a factor
.  You're curious, aren't you
?  It's based on wages.  Almost all of them.
It seems the bonuses for those working at Samsung Electronics and SK Hynix have a significant impact.   Something like that
.
Capital gains are not included.
Only income generated through production activities is included.
Looking at this, in a way, GDI has
increased significantly, but there are also separate factors that directly influence the
actual wealth effect, such as capital gains or rising housing prices
.   That's right
.  Looking at that, the consumer sector stocks are
completely crashing right now, but in
a way, there could be an opportunity here
.  Right?  yes.  I
think that is possible.   There are a lot more
people in the evenings these days.   Is
n't that the case in the past?
Well, I don't really
go to places like department stores either, but when I earn some money from stocks or my
paycheck comes in, I try to eat something fancy.
Since I'm eating things I couldn't even imagine about 3 or 4 years ago, I think my
defense has
improved a lot compared to before.
Our President Choi Bu also has absolutely nothing to do with department stores or
shopping, so it does
n't matter.  But I found that there are people like that
.  I feel
proud of those people. I feel
proud when I hear them say things like, "I made money through stocks to pay for my child's tuition, and it helped buy government products."   That's right
.  Salt, you're back from your trip too,
right?
If you look at the comments on the Woshinbang forum, surprisingly, there are quite a few posts saying things like, "
Oh, I went on a trip somewhere," as people focused on this recent event
.  That is correct.   For
those who are really flexing with the PlayStation, look
here. I also think that I am now
buying it without looking at the price of tofu.
[Laughs]
That's right.
Oh, the main point of the reporter is still a
reasonable story.  Right?   Okay,
and for the next report,
instead of the growing short-range anti-aircraft system market, you brought
Researcher Choi Jong-won's data.
I have a very positive view of the defense industry right now, so I keep bringing it up
.   It is described as a
growing market for short-term strategies, and it was mentioned that there are
still valid investment points
remaining, along with
talk of lowered valuations.  Since the first quarter
earnings announcement, there has been a
continuous lull in new orders. Just last year and the year before,
news of new orders was
pouring in every quarter, and the stock price
was pumped up tremendously, remember?   While
talk of new orders has quieted down considerably, and the
stock prices of domestic defense contractors continue to
underperform, I mentioned that there might be some acceleration in the Middle East business, which had been delayed due to the end of the war in the U.S.  The
current
stock price appears to be an attractive price for investors looking for growth within the structure of the business
.  We have maintained a
buy rating on our defense industry coverage company
.  Now, regarding the U.S. Regional
Sustainability Framework, known as RSF, I mentioned that there might be
some opportunities within the Indo-Pacific region
.   It is said that it is
currently difficult for the U.S. alone to meet security needs due to bottlenecks in the defense industry, and that the U.S. has elevated the Indo-Pacific region to a core memorandum hub by signing the
RSF and
Security Industry Resilience Partnership with allies such as South Korea in 2024. It is
predicted that this could serve as an opportunity for the domestic defense industry after the upgrade.
In the modern structure centered on low-cost mass production of weapons and manufacturing capabilities, Korea can be
viewed as the optimal Asian partner country capable of providing the manufacturing base that the United States requires.
Hana Aero is said to be producing weapons such as the
K9, Chunmoo, and Redback through its facilities in Korea, Australia, and India, and
together with its subsidiaries, it
can fill the power gap resulting from the U.S. policy of security division across various sectors, including aerospace and ground operations
.  And well, above all else, the most
important thing is Europe.  It is said that despite the
strengthening of the France-centered European awakening theory, the
joint development program for 6th-generation fighter jets pursued by France and Germany has been
officially halted,
confirming that national economic interests take precedence over political logic
.  Consequently, the
likelihood of a delay in the integration of the European defense industry has
increased, and this
could be utilized as an opportunity for the Korean defense industry.
In addition to expanding direct sales, they also mentioned localization strategies based in Eastern Europe and
other strategies, and stated that LIG
DNA Line Metal has established a joint venture this time
.  It is said that
increased exports are expected through cooperation such as the partnership between HANA ERO Space and Thales
. This partnership between HANA ERO and
Thales was a topic that came up even over the weekend
.   In the
Middle East, demand for defense industry self-reliance among Middle Eastern countries will increase in line with the U.S.’s concentrated strategy and the
expansion of strategic autonomy among these nations
.
And I also talked about short-range air defense measures
.  This is SHAD, which stands for Short
Range AeroDefense. It can be described as a
missile designed for short-range air defense.
Due to the technical nature of laser-based anti-aircraft weapon systems, there are
prospects for rapid response to drone threats.
The market for cluster bombs, explosive rounds, and explosive-based anti-aircraft guns is expected to grow.
Domestically, examples include Hanayo’s
H-Short Rad and LIS DNA
102 2 LSAM.   It is
said that when they are one by one, one needs to pay attention to things like blue light.   The U.S. is
continuously
putting pressure on Europe, and within Europe itself,
there are plans to increase defense spending to 4% of GDP.   hmm.
Accordingly, it needs to be
fully introduced into air defense missile systems, and the
LI [clearing the throat] DNA One
Aerospace One System
can benefit from this.  It can be interpreted as a story
.  Because, just like with Cheongtu,
LSM is also included, and all three companies are
involved.  It seems that World History's capabilities
point to that aspect as an investment point
.
[Clears throat] Well, the
investment point still hasn't been compromised, right?   It
is a flexible investment point, and since prices are now
falling, you
can buy stocks at increasingly lower prices.
That was the content.
Now, there was a big surprise in our country's market yesterday, and
Hynix
rose to first place in total market capitalization.  Right?   It
looks like that atmosphere will probably continue today.   yes
.  Strangely enough, I am currently in the red
.
It seems like night futures went up about 1.9% yesterday, but the index is currently in the
negative.
How did the market start? Yes, it started
down 0.34%
.  Uh, now the gains have just started to come in
.   There is a
0.08% increase, and Electronic
Inix is ​​in the negative.  Uh,
what about KOSDAQ? Yes, yes.  The KOSDAQ started down 1%
.  It is currently
rising by +0.21% to 21%
.
[Clears throat] Well, people say that if you add preferred shares, the
former has a larger market capitalization,
but if you include preferred shares, the
PER might be calculated slightly higher, and
Hynix is ​​issuing ADRs this time, you know
.
That is issuing new shares and listing them in the U.S.
yes.  I am doing that
.  yes.  So I
think there will be some controversy later on.  For Hynix, you have to
look at the combined market capitalization of the US ADRs
.  So, if we have to
look at Samsung Electronics including preferred shares like this,
[laughs] you know.   Since it
's a collectible that has already been issued anyway,
[snorting]
if you look at it all together as an ADR, it
seems like Hynix might maintain its number one position in market capitalization a little longer,
right?  It seems like it could continue for another month or two, and
it could
become entrenched,
yes.   I'm
not sure what scale the ADR is currently issuing new shares for.   They said it was
10.5% of the total.
2.5%.
Uh, 2.5%.
yes.  It is 2.5% of the total, and
once it is listed on Nasdaq, it
can be included in the Philippine Index, but
that Philippine Index is based on free-float market
capitalization.  So, if
you look, TSMC and ASMR have
large market caps, you know.  But there is something behind it
.  Because it is based on the flow start and end
.  So, it is
true that Hynix is ​​included in the PfL index, but
since its impact is based on liquidity,
there is a possibility it might fall behind. However, in my view,
simply being listed in the U.S. will
definitely have the effect of increasing its multiple.
So, Micron is currently trading tenfold and
Hynix sevenfold, but I do have a
hope that it would be nice if they could go up to eight, nine, or even sevenfold
.
Yes, I mean about 2.5% is applied.
Yes, that is what I know.
Then that's about 2.5 trillion out of 2,000 trillion
.  They issued new shares worth about 40 trillion or 45 trillion,
used that to drive Ray's growth,
and then
immediately bought back treasury shares equivalent to the issued shares
.
Ah, since we buy back and cancel treasury shares equal to the number of issued shares, we
originally intended to
list them daily based on the existing treasury shares so that the total number of shares would not change, but we are hoping that we can no longer
use them due to judicial accounting
.
And when I went to New York, I
visited a small brokerage firm called Cittade a Cittaderiane Stiberi, and the head of the
research center there gave me a tour of the trading room
.  So, there are a
few dozen people trading there, and it is a
conditional stock called Stifel—no, not Stifel—and it is listed on the stock exchange
.  It is a securities firm with a market capitalization of about 10 to 12 billion
dollars, and they say it is a
firm that collaborates with Korea Investment & Securities in New York.
So, for some reason, I went to that trading room and
talked to those people, and they said they do
stocks, bonds, interest rates, and everything
else.  So we
asked if they had any exposure to Korea, but they said they didn't
.  When I asked why they didn't have it, they said it was
n't possible because they only trade during the day and the time difference was the
issue.  So, we can
contact each other or whatever if necessary,
but anyway, regarding that Korean asset itself,
[snorting] if it continues to be
listed on the US side, I think buying will definitely increase
.  yes.
Now, if this ADR grows, the multiple will be compared with Micron as well,
yes.  Uh, there were many ADRs and GDRs
listed in the U.S. in the past, but
ultimately, regarding the result, you
always need to understand that this is arbitrage
.  There are arbitrage opportunities, you know
.  Then, hatch funders come in
like hyenas to snatch up that arbitrage machine
.  That involves options,
futures, rest futures, convertible bonds, and BWs;
arbitrage is
calculated for all of them, and viper-like players come in
.  Then, for example,
Hynix, worth about 50 trillion won,
gets listed.  While
rising multiples in the U.S. could potentially boost our country's 2 trillion won market, and we have
high expectations for that, if
we look at how GDRs and ADRs were traded in the past, the difference between the valuation of the Korean stock market and
U.S. GDRs was
utilized for
differential trading. For instance, when U.S. GDRs
became more expensive,
U.S. hatch funds would
buy undervalued Korean stocks.
This would cause the gap to
narrow. Furthermore, if
ADRs are included in indices and strong buying pressure flows in to pull them up, the
stock price will rise even if short sellers take positions there.
Consequently, investors would need to
take long positions on domestic stocks while holding short positions there, potentially leading to an increase in
domestic stocks. However, as
various differences
arise, we will likely
see a pattern where these multiples are neutralized
.
Well, the market is fluctuating right now
.   yes
.  Uh, it looks like Hynix is ​​slightly in the upside and
Samsung Electronics is slightly in the downside. And
regarding
how to determine the timing for selling semiconductors this time using the spot price and fixed transaction price that Manager Seon-gu established, I
discussed that a bit at the talk concert during my lecture at Myongji University yesterday.
Someone mentioned it earlier,
so if you go and take a look, I
was just mentioning Cheong Gi-nu, but since
we will be doing a
monthly forecast next time, I will
explain it in detail then as well
.  Okay, in the US market yesterday, it looks like
Uripro might
drop a little.  I thought the SP 500 would drop, and it did
.
I said that SP would fall but the Nasdaq would still rise, but the Nasdaq fell even more significantly
.  Oh, this is because of SpaceX earlier, right?  Right
?  Space.
But I was right about seeing that flow.
What happens today?   I actually
think that both will drop again today because of SpaceX.
First off, there is the Micron earnings announcement tomorrow, which in a
way is seen as a positive catalyst for the stock itself.
However, considering the SPs and the business segments they occupy,
Big Tech companies are larger, but it feels like SpaceX is
dragging the overall sentiment down, so I
think the market will decline.
Also, the support level for SpaceX's IPO was around
$160, but
that has now been broken.  It just finished at around $154. I
thought the IPO price was $13, but the closing price for that day was $
162.
So, we'll have to
wait and see if it drops to the offering price, but I think it won't
fall tomorrow because there isn't any particular catalyst to drive it up
.   yes
.  Decline until tonight.   yes
.  It's both NASDAQ and SP.
Even up until we were discussing how to handle Pilbar, things had
n't been concluded yet, but the
atmosphere improved a bit when the NASDAQ was concluded at the end of our meeting.
And
regarding what happened, uh, the Memorandum of Understanding with the U.S. and Japan... ah, yes, it is a Memorandum of Understanding. So,
I will predict a rise.
Oh, Micron is releasing its earnings report after the market closes today, but it's the day after
tomorrow
.  Yes, from our perspective, it is
Thursday morning, so
yes, the
upward trend will prevail.
Yes, so the
KOSPI had a bullish candle yesterday. Did it get a
bullish candle?   Yes, yes.
How is the beekeeping today?   As I
mentioned yesterday, I believe
the market is likely to remain strong until Mycon's earnings report, so I
think there is a higher probability that it will start low today and end with a bullish candle.   It was a bullish candle
until today, and Costa
was a bearish candle yesterday, but somehow,
yesterday I paid my annual salary.
Ah, based on the annual salary, the
atmosphere today turned even more bearish
.
Uh, today's bearish candle.   yes
.  It is a bearish candle.
Uh, I talked about the bearish candle yesterday as well, and although a bullish candle
appeared, that is correct.
The system continues to show bearish candles today as well.   yes
.  A negative candle was issued.
Yeolpyeong mentioned that statistic at the beginning, but since the
starting point is different,
yes.  It's coming out that way because it's twisted.   yes
.
Uh, I take all of that into account when I
look at it.
Yeol-nim, add that to the statistics
.   If you compare it to that,
Dr. Wang, yes, it's pretty
similar to this one.
So,
since it is a meticulous fortress wall that is easy to manage, it
seems you got a sense of it because it didn't fit, but I would appreciate it if you could
continue to provide the statistics, Yeol
.
Ah, I’d like to thank our staff for preparing the Morning Brief materials again today. Also, thank you to everyone in the
comments section for
actively sharing so much;
reading the comments is really
helpful to me, too.  So, thank you for sharing your
various opinions. As I
mentioned earlier, since the market is a
place where only the skilled can reap the rewards, let's
listen to the morning monitor with Chaesli.
Sometimes,
there are people who bought neglected stocks and are stuck with them, but the
characteristic of this market is that it is
not a market that will collapse.   yes
.  And the reason it’s not a collapsing market is that it has
risen based on performance.
And because semiconductor performance is so good, there is a
severe concentration on the semiconductor sector right now. As Manager Oh mentioned earlier, the
defense industry,
shipbuilding, and even
Samhyung Foods—which is missing from the list—have decent earnings, but due to
various supply and demand
factors and sentiment, that
sentiment is being somewhat [sneered] because of the fact that the Fed is
n't raising interest rates this time.
So, in 2022, there was a
[snor] in January and a [
war] in February, but after the
first 25bp interest rate hike in March, there was a
strong rebound in March and April
.  Right?  yes.  Then
in May, they raised it by 50bp from 25, and I was like, "Huh,
what?"  Because the market collapsed from the moment people realized that interest rates were being
raised in a pocket-sized manner rather than a baby step as we had expected, the
market was actually
trembling a bit in advance.   That is the
pattern in advance.  Even if they raise interest rates this time, they will only
raise them once or twice.   Right
?  They're only going to
go up by about 25p once or twice,
so looking at it that way, I think this correction is a significant
opportunity to buy stocks at a cheap price. So, if there is a
stock I am confident in that keeps
falling, I
[clear my throat]
keep buying and keeping it. After that, what you
need to do is pray for I-Pre and
keep studying.
Yes.
yes.  And the very reason interest rates and prices are currently under
some upward pressure is that,
in fact, there was a
cosmic effect in 2022 because of the war.   As
oil prices rose significantly due to disruptions on the supply side,
yes.
yes.  If it played a role in driving up prices,
now that oil prices are
easing slightly and
capital expenditures are increasing sharply in the Bitcoin sector,
it is a demand-driven rise in prices or interest rates.  So, I
think the texture is a bit different.  That is
why I think that if we specifically
pick and
take on companies with strong performance records, we might actually be able to achieve differentiated results
.
Now, for today's closing remarks, we will go with Key By,
then Key Study and
Key Pray. Yes, yes, please
pray as well. Yes, I
think that is how you should invest. That concludes the Chasslyn Morning
Brief for today, Tuesday, June 23rd
.
Thank you to everyone for being with us.